Well, to get this x squared, we multiplied x times x. And, to get this 9x
squared, we multiplied 3x times 3x. So, we just squared the first term. If I
squared the first term here I would get A squared. This middle term is a little
bit trickier. If I do 4 times x I have 4x. But I don't need one of them, I need
two. So I'm going to have 2 times my first term and my second term. The same is
true down here. I don't just have one 3x, I have two. So I'm going to have the
first term times the second term, times 2. So here's the first term, a, times
the second term, b, times 2. I listed the 2 first, since we usually put
coefficients in front of variables. Now we need to think about the last term,
the 16 and the 1. Well I know 4 squared is 16, and 1 squared is 1. So to get the
last term, all I need to do is square the second term. So we square the b, we
add b squared. Here's a general pattern we could always use if we ever have to
square a binomial. Now, you don't have to memorize this, but this is helpful in
these particular cases. If you do commit this to memory, or continue to
recognize the pattern, it will help you out in later lessons.